good morning believe nation today's
message is stay open
over to you Queen Latifah you want to
grab me you've got like the nomination
for an Oscar you want to sign the where
you want to go the wall but you just so
much like how do you keep going like
what inspired you
honestly I pray always the table you
know if you always learning something
moving and you have you can be inspired
but I don't just kind of sit and look at
the past like I did this until people
like you remind me a lot of stuff I
don't really you know think about them
in the same way because I see the new
things on the horizon and I don't feel
like I have to do the same thing over
and over I think if you're a creative
person then you kind of have to follow
your vibe it's been opportunity and
there was something interesting that you
know how it's sparking and then you go
for it and I was just kind of never one
of those people who felt like I couldn't
yeah I've got the right people around me
that I believe to do anything for genres
they don't have for everything that
you've done
I don't master at all but I persevered
through it all and it gives me a chance
to find the next thing to work on so I'm
a fighter you know I know how to take
them as much as I can give them so
that's what we do so I think it's really
important for entrepreneurs that we stay
really focused and stubborn on our one
word our values and the mission of what
we're trying to accomplish you know what
we will not tolerate in our life but be
open to everything else and I think this
is where people fall down I think people
are too attached to the how and not
enough attached to the why so let me
explain you want to start a business you
want to you want to take it to some big
heights right I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs with my business I want to
do it to believe those two things are
non-negotiable I want to have a big
impact I want to do something that has
the potential to help a billion
entrepreneurs and I'm going to do it
through belief it's my one word it's the
most important core value that I have
I'm not going to do it
in a way that puts people down the goal
is not that important that I would trash
people or throw stones at people or make
people look bad to achieve my goal it
would actually be easier if this was a
negative Channel this was the ten
biggest failures of all these people
these are the ten stupid things that
this person did I would get a lot more
views because in general people would
rather laugh at somebody than trying to
build them up because we want to just
escape our own life and seeing how other
people have had failure and how crappy
their life is it makes us feel better
about ourselves that's not what I want
to build believe is too important to me
those two things are non-negotiable big
impact a billion entrepreneurs through
belief everything else is open right now
it's through the book it's to my website
it's through social media to my youtube
channel those are the main areas that
I'm focusing my time on if YouTube stops
allowing me to have the impact that I'm
looking for I'll move somewhere else
I'll stop doing the channel if I can get
way more impact through believe writing
books maybe that's where I start
focusing my attention and I think too
many of you are focused to the how not
stubborn and focus enough on the why and
what the big thing is and to focus on
the how or recognize that your how will
change if you look at the the story of
any successful entrepreneur you'll see
that the how change the planet they
started with is never the plan that gets
you to where you end up having your
ultimate goal it always changes that's
not to say don't plank plan is important
it's not just go out and see what works
you have to have a plan but understand
is the plane is going to change and if
you are not open and you're stuck and
only having it happen through this plan
you're likely going to fail this is a
special shoe when you start bringing
people on under you my goal with the
people on my team is I want to help get
a billion entrepreneurs and we're going
to do it to the value of belief give me
ideas how do we get there let me unlock
your talents your genius your creativity
to help me get there let's do this
together because if all you're going to
do is exactly what I tell you to do
we're always going to be restricted you
know and I learned this lesson in my
first business where I spent too
time planning and planning and planning
and planning and I lost out on a huge
deal because I over planned I think a
lot of us get stuck on the how because
we've invested time energy effort money
into one path which may or may not be
the path right like I bought lights and
I've got a cameraman and I've got
editors and I've got this team around
building a YouTube channel it'd be hard
to walk away from especially other
people's jobs are on the line as well
but if it's not helping me accomplish
what I want to accomplish then I have to
do it I have to make that tough decision
to go out and do something out now don't
freak out I'm not going anywhere YouTube
is a great platform I love it this is
amazing I look forward to my family days
and all you guys in the comments but if
it came to that I might have to switch
to something else in my original plan
YouTube wasn't part of it I never wanted
to be YouTube famous it was to my
website that all these things are going
to happen and I adjust it because I was
getting a lot more awareness a lot more
traction a lot more fun through the
youtube channel and that may change
again in a year two years five years 20
years or never stubbornness around the Y
stubbornness around your one word core
value and complete flexibility and
openness around everything else that's
the key so the question is they tell you
is I'm curious what are the
non-negotiables for you what's the Y for
you what's the big thing you're trying
to build and what's your one word core
value put it in the comments below to be
curious to find them I also want to give
a quick shout out to Brenda and Bill
Shriner thank you guys so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really means a lot to me I hope
you're learning some good lessons that
you're applying to your business into
your life and I appreciate the support
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day
I believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in yourself and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events better
oh it's great Oh give me
[Music]
I think the secret to my career is I
don't know what I can't do you know
they'd be taught there are times when I
should probably sit and think but I
really want to jump you know jump out
there with Philip Seymour I mean with
Riley and and and seeing you know the
night Chicago died or don't really want
to play the blues with little ed or you
know and I you just do it you just do
these things and uh and you become the
audience wants you to do these things
yeah I think what's what's I don't know
what it is but I think over the years
people have gotten comfortable with the
notion that I try things
it's almost their desk and they're not
worried about me do you know what I mean
I I think that's the key people aren't
worried about me getting hurt because I
can you know I'll give it a hundred
percent and then if it completely falls
on its face I'll laugh about it and move
on
and I think there's a little bit of a
sense after all these years people say
you know all right he tried it maybe it
worked maybe it didn't work but he had a
good time and for you you can come back
the next night in the next night or the
next night mm-hmm
you know I mean that's you know the I
don't know there's a there's a there's a
over the years I've realized that there
are a lot of comedians that are very you
know worried about keeping their dignity
intact you know and keeping their
personal space and keeping their sense
of authority and for better or worse and
it might be worse I don't have that you
know you don't I mean I'm not the people
that I've always liked growing up and
I'm not just talking about late-night
community I'm talking about anybody in
movie in film and you know the people I
liked Peter Sellers they would let it
all hang out he just go you know if you
look at a lot of those old classic
Carson clips he's jumping into hot tubs
with done with Don Rickles he's jumping
through fake walls he's you know he's
falling on his ass he's dressed his
Floyd turbot and you know so sometimes I
look back to that and I remembered well
you know Johnny Johnny just just went
for it
you know for better or worse you know
I'll try I'll get out there and I'm very
physical and I'm my wife is always
horrified I'm always coming out of the
shower just covered in bruises and
she'll say what was that I'll say oh I
did a bit you know we had you know Jeff
Garlin on the show and he and I rolled
down a flight of steps you know and I
and I hit a fire hydrant and achieved
the goals I wanted in the in the karate
world I did you know in the world title
and my schools and I was trying to
decide what new energy that was great
and where I want to direct my energies
at and Steve McQueen who was one of my
students at the time suggested the
acting field and I just finished a movie
with Bruce Lee called return the dragon
so I decided I would pursue pursue debt
have a mind that is open to everything
and attached to nothing one of the
central principles of my life is that no
one knows enough to be a pessimist about
anything and that each and every one of
us when we close our mind to what is
possible for us or what is possible for
Humanity closes off the genius that
resides and lives in each and every one
of us having an open mind doesn't
necessarily mean finding fault with all
of the things that you've been taught by
others it means opening yourself up to
the potentiality and the possibility
that anything and everything is possible